there is swimming the little shark is
super cute yes Oregon's John hi Stan is
playing shark midwife with a package
from a pet store nature is weird
biology explain this this is a Brown
banded bamboo shark and that sac is
actually its egg most baby sharks mature
inside eggs inside their mothers bodies
but Brown banded bamboo sharks are a
little unusual they're born from eggs
that mature outside their mothers bodies
this is called oviparous reproduction
the SHA egg is made of collagen collagen
is actually very common in animal bodies
it's used in connective tissue and skin
for example and in those kinds of
contexts it needs to be very very
flexible the egg actually starts out
kind of soft and squishy but when it
sits in seawater for a while it starts
to harden and toughen and become this
thick leathery thing that you can see
John cutting through but without
scissors how are they born in the wild
after about a month inside the egg a
crack develops at one end and that
allows sea water in which carries oxygen
in and that's important for the Sharks
development this opening also provides
an exit for the shark when it's fully
formed and in this case what we're
seeing is John helping the process along
by cutting it out he's not harming the
shark in any way yes nature is just a
awesome algae